when did you read your first
screenwriting book in which oh my first
one I think my first one was actually
save the cat which is a really good book
and it was about outlining if anybody
wants to be a filmmaker I would suggest
that book save the cat if you want to be
a filmmaker it lays out structure really
well and now everything doesn't have to
be formulaic but everything's almost
been done at this point so I mean even
when I'm making the movie now where I'm
making a okay this movie about the book
catches the white tiger it's about it's
a biopic so I go and I watch all biopics
and what what kind of biopic don't want
to make wolf of Wall Street is very
different than the founder unit I mean
so the blueprints there in a way you
know so that helps you make a blueprint
that book and but I feel like books were
helpful that's a very helpful book but I
felt like watching movies was the most
helpful for me you know like my brother
who's my writing partner will send me
scripts and be like here you know he
just sent me he's like three scripts
yesterday of all these biopics I'd
rather watch the movies because I'm very
much I know that a script can change so
much and compared to making the movie
and so when you're seeing it in the
movie it might be an improv it might
would be whatever but that could still
be a script even it maybe it wasn't a
script it could have been a script if
you would wrote it that way
so I kind of like watching the final
product more than reading the script in
the sense of learning when it comes to
like Goodfellas reading the script or
watching the movie I'd rather watch the
movie and analyze that then actually
read the script but my brother is the
opposite so it just depends on what how
you learned and you can get your hands
nowadays with the internet you get your
hands on so many scripts and so many
things and learn so much you can read
the script for Goodfellas you know when
I was it when I was young the kid you
know you could never get your hands on a
script like that unless you went to it
like American film institution or one of
these big film schools that have those
kind of scripts then you could read it
and learn from it but nowadays I mean
people can learn so easily with the
Internet
it's just it's a great thing if you want
to learn what three scripts did he send
you
ah he sent me wolf of wallstreet I think
he sent me founders and he sent me good
fellows that's why I brought them all up
so I think I opened wolf of wallstreet
who read the first couple pages and I
was like I don't know watch the movie
but I don't know if I'll read it or not
I know he's read it but he's my writing
partner so you know I would like to read
him just for fun but I feel like now is
the time that really for me I get more
from a movie than a script because I'm a
filmmaker
he's a script writer so you know he's
more of a script like he wants to just
be a script writer my brother Charlie
Ward me I want to be a filmmaker and an
actor I don't really I write scripts out
of necessity I don't really want to
write scripts it's like I write them
because I don't have a script you know
and I've been blessed with the fact that
at least I know structure well and I get
I've watched god I used to watch two
three movies I used to watch two three
movies a day when I was a kid you know
we moved I moved from Philadelphia when
I was a kid to Roseburg glide Oregon
when I was 12 years old and there was
nothing to do I went from the mall and
the skating rink to like okay there's a
lot of trees around there's nothing to
do the first neighbors like a mile away
well I would just watch movies like
crazy you know so I'd watch two three
movies a day half the time all my free
time was spent watching movies are
outside running around and they I've
heard it before you gotta watch ten you
got to spend ten thousand hours on your
craft to really be a master at it well
I've easily watched you know over 10,000
hours of movies to gotten to where I've
gotten and honestly that's what makes
you an artist in a way because if you
haven't the things that used to shock me
and impress me and intrigue me when I
was a kid watching movies are different
than what they do now because I've seen
so many of them so it's different you
know you can think back to the time of
when it did but ultimately now I have so
much more
of a library in my head of movies that
now you're competing with all those as
to where if I only saw seven movies this
movie's amazing but it's only competing
with six but if you watch 10,000 hours
or whatever now I've seen Godfather and
the Goodfellas in there they're both
mafia movies now they're competing
against each other and so some people
nowadays that they say oh I I this is my
favorite movie but they've never seen
all these movies in the 70s and 80s and
I'm thinking well yeah but you don't
really you don't know your craft i mean
you know you haven't spent the time to
watch all those movies and and really
learn your craft you know would you say
Charlie's good at one part of
screenwriting and you're good at the
other or I mean like how do you work
together with a partner how is that um
with Seth it was different so Seth Himes
and me wrote while he got wasted charlie
is writing this new movie with me two
very different writing partners for me
so Seth really wanted to put the words
on the page and so I would basically do
the outline and then he would go off and
write by himself and then come bring it
back to me and then I'd read it make all
these corrections on the page and be
like the scene doesn't hit this moment
it does I need this moment and this is
like like as an example this is the low
of the movie like these guys have to
turn on each other I need a good
monologue here of him turning on him and
no hope you know and that was one of the
scenes that Seth couldn't end up doing
on his own but most of them I'd give him
notes and then he would go and make
funny moments and and do certain things
and he would change it and write it and
then like the lo of the movie and while
he got wasted there on a cliffside
overlooking all of Los Angeles he could
never get that scene so I was like okay
I'll write it so then I wrote that scene
and the jokes in in her mind but the
jokes and the other scenes are his and
so we it's nice to write in a group
attached from a theory I wrote on my own
by myself but while he got wasted was
with Seth and then there's new ones with
my brother and my brother my brother and
me Ben range scrim since I was scripts
since I was a child so we have very much
shorthand with each other
of like thinking a lot of the same
things and stuff like that but he as
well doesn't it's funny I have not found
anybody that we like to write page words
on the page together it's kind of like
he goes off and writes I go off and
write and we come together it's I I've
yet to find somebody that likes to write
in the room together but that would be
interesting it would be a dream come
true in a way it'd be fun and I've done
that with my brother but parole officers
we did together but I acted out all the
characters in the living room and he sat
there and would type so I'm like living
the characters and saying what they
would say and then he's like writing
them down so it's very different process
with parole officers on that but most of
them had people want to write alone you
know they want their creativity to you
know quiet and and all that kind of
stuff so I was just different
you